parent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai en moins de baffin sert des
clients des grands jours de moins en
moins d'assists c'est lamentable
c'est facile de remplir les gymnases en
même temps bien evelyne est ce que vous
préférez vous faire draguer ou draguer
mais est ce que vous préférez embrasser
ou vous faire embrasser
2 quel est le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte niveau michel je disais je suis
tranquille
c'est tombé sur brics le lien bien un
dc10 l'avait déjà fait en marchant
et quand on va dire mais plus de lustre
marais vous avez vos secrets
quel est l'endroit où vous êtes
incapable de faire l'amour au milieu des
gens n'ont pas du tout avait changé
c'est évidemment je suis désolé tirer
est-ce que vous avez c'est très
important ça est-ce que vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour ou de faire
l'amour pourrait mais j'ai besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour est ce que
vous préférez un homme qui fait bien
l'amour mais qu'un infidèle ou un homme
qui fait mal d'amour mais qui est fidèle
si je peux avoir les deux d'accord vous
faites forte de l'apprendre
est ce que vous préférez qu'ils couchent
avec une autre en pensons à vous qui
couche avec vous en pensant à une autre
les bonnes réponses
je préfère
aa c'est sa réponse j'ai peur qu'il faut
jamais qu'une avec une autre en pensant
à moi d'ailleurs est-ce que vous
conservez un fantasme non réalisés bien
sûr facilement vrai c'est pas mon genre
non non est ce que vous pensez qu'on
peut tout faire quand on aime non abbas
est sexuellement
ouais on est pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu